[Music]
it's quite the storm we're having
it seems vimble winter's here to stay
it will pass though
all things too
in the meantime how about a story will
be worn by the fire
owns filthy spies
that old man sees more now than he did
when he had both eyes
ah
one of my favorites
it's a story of adventure
a father and son working together to
overcome insurmountable odds setting
emotion the greatest war the nine realms
have ever seen
i'm getting a bit ahead of myself
let's start from the beginning
there once was a god from a far-off land
who settled in midgard disguised as a
man
he started a new life had a wife and a
boy
they were happy together
in peace they found joy
his wife passed away kratos mourned with
his son
but where one journey ended
anew had begun
fey's final request though it seemed
rather bleak
spread my ashes atop the nine realms
tallest peak
as they readied themselves for the long
road ahead a stranger accosted them in
their homestead
baldur sought answers as odin's hand
kratos gave none to the acer fire
firebrand
they made way for the mountains kratos
taught the boy's skills keeping godhood
a secret but training to kill
gods were always in danger this kratos
knew but secrets he'd learn
could harm the boy too
they found mimir in a tree
punishment for his wrongs so they lopped
off his head
and they brought him along mimir held
ancient wisdom and knew the lost god of
war
he warned tell the boy but kratos
ignored
no no now hold on a minute is that all
that's in there about me something to
add actually yes i do
you see odin and all of his dreadfully
paranoid wisdom trapped me in that
bloody tree for perceived wrongs and i
led quite the colorful life before even
meeting him
it all started when i was just a lad in
the service of a great fairy king
riveting stuff really
we'll have to get back to that later no
don't turn the page i wasn't finished
if amir were telling the story
we'd be here all day
anyways
they met freya
masquerading as a witch in the woods a
god knows a god
she would aid where she could she
cautioned you must tell your son he's
divine but kratos dismissed her
he'd regret this in time
on the road balder's allies thor's sons
attacked
something snapped in atreus as he tried
to fight back
the acer lost the battle but atreus fell
too
kratos rushed him to freyja she would
know what to do
freya was disheartened with the father's
neglect but
with the heart of hell's troll
she could save his son yet
kratos thundered through helheim and
slew the great troll he had captured its
heart
but in his
burned a hole
he returned with his offering freya cast
a keen spell and atreus was healed
though
not all was well
kratos sat with his son and for once he
was true
revealing he was a god
and atreus was too
delighted at first it seemed all would
go smoothly then arrogance followed and
bent atreus toward cruelty
with tensions flared balder prayed on
their discord casting back into hellheim
kratos and his wart
in helheim they learned freya caused
baldur's plight his mother's
ill-conceived curse robbed his life of
all light
they emerged from the realm as they
neared journey's end but balder appeared
and attacked once again
atreus and kratos were ready this time
stronger together with their power
combined
freya
intervened on behalf of her son begging
baldur's forgiveness for all that she'd
done
baldur strangled his mother kratos
lunged with a snap balder slumped freya
wailed
and he died
in her lap
something changed in the world
snow started to fall
the dawn of fimble winter
the dusk of it all
atreus asked is this what it means to be
gods killing our parents forever at odds
no
kratos bellowed as he dropped to one
knee
we will be the gods that we choose to be
finally together they reached the great
peak
finding yottenheim's temple the giants
retreat
a prophetic mural showed the life they
had led the boy's mother was giant they
learned as they read
atreus walked to the cliffside
kratos eyed the wall slowly
beneath the boy's picture a name was
etched
loki
they scattered her ashes and watched as
they lifted over rolling red hills the
wind danced
and it drifted
standing side by side
feeling hopeful and new the boy was at
peace
and the father was too
with their promise fulfilled they
returned to their home they trained day
after day lest they'd reap what they'd
sown
atreus restless
wary kratos remained
ragnarok loomed as the great winter
waned
don't tell me you're thinking of
stopping here things were just getting
good well
i suppose we could go on a bit longer
an excellent idea this is the most
dramatic part
on second thought perhaps we'd better
cut it short
it seems that we are out of time
if you want to know how this story ends
i'm afraid you'll have to find out for
yourself
until then
[Music]
playstation